These are the blooms of prune trees.
Located in a geologic trough, the
Santa Clara Valley in California
was once known as the
Valley of Heart's Delight
due to its farmland filled with
flowers and fruit, including prunes.
How did a region known for
its fruit and flowers...
become an intellectual capital?
During World War II,
American engineer
Vannevar Bush basically led
wartime R&D.
And in 1945
he published an essay called
“Science: The Endless Frontier”.
Bush reported to President Roosevelt that
the pioneer spirit is still vigorous
within this nation.
Though focused partly on problems
like the war against disease...
the report also set an expectation...
that science and continuing science funding...
was necessary for the public welfare.
Just a few years later, the National
Science Foundation resulted
as Harry Truman wrote, Henry Ford
to promote industrial development
in national defense.
This funding meant facilities
like NASA's Ames then called NACA...
and Navy stations near San Francisco,
provided a continuing
engineering talent base to
the San Francisco Bay Area.
That was paired with proximity
to Stanford University...
the college that had greater
land resources than cash.
Built from the land grant
of Leland Stanford
the university was land rich.
You can see in this early proposal
how a small campus was
surrounded by farmland.
But Stanford didn't have
a ton of cash.
The region had a lot of unrealized potential...
and one of Vannevar Bush's
former students...
wanted to realize it.
Frederick Terman was a professor of
electrical engineering at Stanford
as well as an iconic name in radio science.
He worked on stuff like jamming Nazi radar
during World War II
and he also wrote a radio engineering textbook
that sold hundreds of thousands of copies.
Even before Terman was appointed
university provost in 1955
as a professor and as a dean,
he sought ways to develop
the Valley of Heart's Delight.
This 1950s land use study
shows that Stanford intended
to use some of its land
primarily for the campus
and residential development.
Stanford developed the
Stanford Shopping Mall
to help remedy their lack of cash.
It's still leased by the university today.
This is their California Pizza Kitchen.
More importantly...
Terman helped the university develop
Stanford Industrial Park...
today called Stanford Research Park.
This is what it looked like in 1953.
The park provided affordable
99 year leases to tenants
with a strict development plan
to preserve the character of
Palo Alto Construction.
They insisted on low buildings
and preserved grassland...
that the Valley of Heart's Delight
was known for.
But it was more than just a development
on the university's land.
From the beginning,
Terman imagined a new cycle.
Stanford to companies...
to Stanford to companies...
[repeating and overlapping]
to Standford to companies...
As he said in one interview for
Palo Alto 75th anniversary...
“And I would say university made
a major contribution...
to the development here.”
“But then the companies made
a major contribution
to the development of those parts
of the university
that contributed to these companies.”
He encouraged this in many ways
including allowing professors
to spend time in corporate roles
and get corporate paydays...
and helping companies enroll employees
as Stanford students.
He proudly clipped this article
about faculty eggheads
becoming millionaires.
And he gave speeches about how
Stanford is also a source
of highly trained manpower
for those companies...
at a time when such manpower
is in short supply.
Crucially, this cycle wasn't predicated
on silicon or semiconductor companies.
Stanford Industrial Park was open
for any tenant that wanted to be
near Stanford.
Houghton Mifflin,
the book publisher
staked to claim in the Stanford
Industrial Park.
Other hi-tech but not computer-focused companies
also found spots there, as shown
in this 1960 picture.
Here's Terman at the announcement
of a Stanford Research Park building
for SpinCo, a maker of centrifuges
and division of a larger company
looking to expand in Palo Alto.
Stanford's landholdings quickly changed.
You can see how it expanded
through 1955
with 120 acres into
350 acres by 1960.
Terman explicitly said this cycle
would not only affect the Bay Area
but the national labor market.
It worked and in electronics focus
grew from Terman’s own interest
in engineering.
West Coast electronic firms
produced 22%
of the US’s electronic market in 1960,
and it kept growing.
This was a competition between regions.
Terman said if the Midwest continues
to plod along in electronics...
it is destined to become the peon group...
in the nation's electronics industry.
He also argued that growth industries
depend on brains...
and the best source of brains is
the nation's major universities.
Proximity of markets no longer
will play a key role.
This is the Palo Alto garage where
Hewlett-Packard was founded.
Terman had been a teacher.
And his personal solicitations helped
bring them to the West Coast.
And later, a short drive away
in Stanford Industrial Park...
where HP secured a 40-acre site.
Stanford Industrial Park became a platform
for any successful industry that might emerge.
William Shockley's Shockley
Semiconductor Laboratory
is widely credited with starting
the Silicon semiconductor boom...
and Fred Terman solicited Shockley
to start his business
in the Valley.
He did so in nearby Mountain View.
Shockley Semiconductors
became a demonstration of the final cycle
that Terman initiated:
Engineers in the ecosystem
would found new companies
in the same area.
Employees split off Shockley
to form Fairchild Semiconductors
in Mountain View...
and then those employees split off
to form Intel locally...
and so on and so on.
This paired with development
of more recognizable companies
that started in the industrial park.
Renamed the Research Park in 1970.
Xerox's Palo Alto reach center,
PARC was located there.
“This is an experimental office system.”
“It's in use now at the
Xerox research center
in Palo Alto, California.”
As venture capital grew in the 1960s...
bearby Sandhill Road was
an obvious location
due to its proximity
to the Stanford epicenter.
By 1971, journalist Don Hoefler
former publicist for Fairchild Semiconductor
labeled the region Silicon Valley
for a series of articles.
It was an allusion to the silicon chips
that had taken over the valley.
As Hoffler wrote...
The pace has been so frantic that even hardened
veterans of the semiconductor wars...
find it hard to realize that the Bay Area story
covers an era of only 15 years.
The Valley became home to Oracle...
and Next and Adobe
and Sun Microsystems.
And from Netscape on
powered forward...
in the first dotcom boom.
“In 1994 and 95...
Netscape was known as the fastest growing
company in the industry...
with all the requisite valley attributes.”
And even in a remote work era:
Meta, Apple, and Google have all
maintained Silicon Valley...
as a substantial hub.
Terman’s vision made that cycle possible.
And today's Silicon Valley
has fewer prunes...
but it remains in all its complicated ways...
a Valley of Heart's Delight.
Hey, thanks for watching this history
of how Silicon Valley became
Silicon Valley.
But I've got—
One more thing.
Is that corny? No? Should I have
not done that? Anyway.
The map that I use of Stanford Research Park...
It goes up to a certain point in the video...
but it actually comes from a historical survey...
that continues in time.
So I want to show the rest of that to you here.
By 1965, it is up to 500 acres.
That's the yellow area.
The light green area shows you
that it's ballooned to 575 acres by 1970.
By 75, it's at 600 acres.
That's the dark green.
And then you've got the blue,
which shows you up to 1980
which expands Stanford Research Park
to 700 acres.